awesome fortune
that is a sexy name
as a private contractor
you possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
what's that
i went up you said it was clear i said
the front was clear
um
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
[Music]
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stolen
we have to stop that getting onto the
open market
who's the buyer greg simmons to
billionaire arms dealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here
aren't there you can't catch this fish
with conventional lures i'm sorry the
lure being danny francesco
the movie star rick simmons favorite
movie song and how do we get him
blackmail
who's to gear
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager
there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
it's none of you you made that quite
evident when marimba rhythms start to
play i need to be nervous
no reason to be nervous
they're all the killers
you're an actor
act
okay
i'm ready
let's go to work will someone pinch me
please is that danny francesca what's
next for you i'm playing a mysterious
self-made billionaire
you just described me
shadow maybe whoever i do
whatever i do do
whoever greg was buying from was amongst
you last night dear friends
i can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
they're gonna kill you now we'll swim
first
[Music]
we're burnt what do i do the emergency
star is going to melt
[Music]
you stop danny francesca you stopped
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
that's yes do you want seen by anyone
yes or yes you were seen by someone
yes
you